bonsoir bonsoir Patrice alors première
élément qui a été souligné partout et
par vous-même vous aurez désormais si ça
passe beaucoup plus de pouvoir comme
ministre oui vous devenez un Super-Man
d'ailleurs vous avez cité Superman dans
la conférence de prêt j'avais dit à
grand pouvoir grandes responsabilités
mais c'est vrai et c'est parce que ce
qui arrive actuellement Patrice c'est
que à toutes les fois qui arrivent une
décision dans un centre de service ça
finit dans ma cour les oppositions me
disent qu'est-ce que vous attendez pour
changer la décision etc jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai résisté à ça parce que
moi je pense que les centres de services
il faut les ils sont imputables de leur
décision puis si ils prennent une
décision en matière de service de garde
ou de service éducatif c'est à eux au
centre de services donc aux directions
générales d'expliquer leur décision d'en
être imputable devenir répondre à vos
questions etc etc sauf que ça se
pourrait un un moment donné qu'un jour
je sois vraiment en désaccord avec une
décision et que je dois la renverser et
oui je me donne ce pouvoir là j'ai pas
l'intention de l'utiliser ok a priori
mais ça se pourrait qu'un jour et
actuellement je ne l'ai pas le seul
pouvoir que j'ai c'est la tutelle du
centre de service je trouve ça un peu
excessif la question fondamentale puis
je vais vous la poser c'est qu'est-ce
que ça va changer dans les salles de
classe mais juste pour qu'on comprenne
ce que vous venez de dire il y a 72
centres de services scolaire qui ont
remplacé les commissions scolaires bingo
et là vous allez pouvoir non seulement
pouvoir vous allez nommer les patrons de
ces 72 mais c'est moi qui vais
recommander donc c'est vous qui allez
choisir et une fois en place vous allez
décider si tourne à gauche puis il
devait pas tourner à gauche j'ai dit hop
tu devais tourner à droite ça va pas
faire des gens paralysés de peur devant
le pouvoir du ministre non je pense pas
parce que avec la nomination va venir
aussi une ent de gestion et
d'imputabilité à chaque année je vais
conclure avec les directions générales
des objectifs des cibles à atteindre et
donc une forme d'obligation de résultats
puis ça ça se repos de l'arbitrage ça va
être en fonction des orientations que le
ministre aura donné pour le moment c'est
moi et donc moi il y a quoi cet janvier
j'ai dit mes priorités le français des
projets éducatifs des écoles secondaires
des aides à la classe de la formation
professionnelle une voie rapide pour les
légalement qualifiés qui ont un bac pour
qu'ils puissent devenir brevet
enseignants et tout ça efficacité et
puis le dernier c'était les
infrastructures les écoles
directement la même mise sur ses 72
centres là que ça change
pour ce qui est de la gestion moi je
pense que ça va faire en sorte qu'il va
y avoir plus de cohérence puis qu'on va
travailler tout le monde dans la même
direction j'ai 72 supergestionnaires
j'ai 72 premiers dirigeants et là on va
marcher en équipe tout le monde dans la
même direction on va marcher droit de
part de déplaire au ministre mais non
mais non l'idée c'est qu'on se donne des
objectifs communs puis qu'on s'assoit
moi je peux pas les faire atterrir dans
les classes Patrice je peux pas je peux
pas j'ai 3000 écoles au Québec je décide
des grandes orientations puis un moment
donné il faut faire atterrir ça dans les
classes faut s'assurer que les
orientations soient mises en place puis
que donc il y a une cohérence puis un
objectif commun et ça avec les ententes
de gestion et d'imputabilité puis le
corollaire à ça c'est-à-dire si on
travaille bien ensemble on continue puis
je vous le dis là moi là jusqu'à
maintenant j'en ai rencontré beaucoup là
de directeur puis directrice générale je
les trouve excellent je les trouve très
bon mon objectif c'est pas de faire de
table rase mon objectif c'est de les
garder et je vous le dis au terme
d'adoption du projet de loi je vous
prédis que la masse de majorité vont
rester en poste parce qu'ils sont bons
je les trouve bon mais ils vont sentir
l'autorité du ministre pas loin plus
proche qu'elle ne l'étaient peut-être
mais je m'entends bien avec avec eux je
travaille bien avec eux puis je les
trouve bon concret oui cette prof qui a
créé façon épouvantable à ces petits
élèves de première année le directeur
qui a été suspendu depuis
manifestement je sais pas assez vite le
sens scolaire manifestement je sais pas
assez vite les parents se plaignaient
que ça changerait avec votre nouveau
système
ben écoutez actuellement c'est une autre
on s'est mis en lien avec le centre de
service et puis on leur a demandé un
topo de la situation puis l'heure
actuellement il y a une enquête en cours
moi j'ai déclenché une enquête en plus
des enquêtes policières notamment qui
étaient déjà déclenchés alors c'est sûr
Patrice que j'attends les conclusions de
mes enquêteurs si je me rends compte
puis là il faut que je fasse très
attention mais si je me rends compte
qu'effectivement il y a des gestes qui
auraient dû être posés des décisions qui
auraient dû être prises qui ne l'ont pas
été
un moment donné ça se peut que la
confiance soit
remise en question qui est des alors
vous dites vous les amis beaucoup les 72
mais peut-être celle-là ou celui-là et
j'aimerais pas aller là parce que j'ai
pas vu encore les conclusions de
l'enquête mais c'est ceux qui doivent y
avoir édition de compte Patrick c'est un
moment donné moi je me suis pas gêné
pour le dire et puis encore une fois les
DG commencent à me connaître moi je leur
dis dans la loi vous êtes les
porte-paroles de vos centres de service
et vous devez prendre la parole moi mon
expérience avec les commissions
scolaires puis des centres de service
depuis quand j'étais encore dans le
monde des médias c'est qu'il sortait pas
puis moi je leur dis au DG vous devez
sortir ça fait partie de votre job puis
aller rendre compte de vos décisions
qu'ils vont si votre réforme parle ils
vont davantage sortir c'est ça
se sentir appuyé par le ministre ils
vont et est-ce qu'ils vont se permettre
de faire des choses dans leur région
original sans se faire dire t'as pas le
droit de faire ça c'est pas au contraire
moi jusqu'à maintenant là je les ai
appuyés dans leur réforme j'ai fait une
erreur c'est sur le pays des bleuets mon
information était pas exacte je me suis
critiqué puis finalement j'avais pas
raison de critiquer bon puis j'ai fait
mon meilleur couple pas mais depuis il y
a eu plusieurs décisions qui ont été
prises par les centres de service et je
me fais critiquer par les oppositions
qui disent intervient intervient
intervient et je dis à taper là on va
pas tout gérer à partir du 16e étage de
les diffuser un moment donné il faut
aussi que je leur laisse leur autonomie
et que je leur et que je les laisse
prendre le responsabilité dans la salle
de classe
votre réforme passe trois mois après six
mois après un an après en quoi ça
améliore le projet éducatif donné
Patrice actuellement écoute je suis
arrivé en pas je l'ai dit là je me suis
pas caché
ils étaient pas capables de me dire mais
mais sumministes n'était pas capable de
me dire combien d'enseignants il
manquait dans mes classes parce que les
données présentement l'information et
l'appartient au centre de services parce
ce sont les entités légales avec le
projet de loi on crée un cadre où les
donner ils vont être obligés ils vont
être obligés de déposer dans des bases
de données puis moi je vais avoir accès
enfin que je vais savoir en temps réel
ce qui se passe et donc pour répondre à
votre question ça c'est peut-être plus
important que de nommer directement les
c'est aussi important puis peut-être que
pour les élèves ça l'est encore
davantage mais en matière de gestion je
pense qu'elle m'amener un système plus
efficace va produire des meilleurs
résultats on est peut-être plus dans du
moyen terme mais dans le cas des données
on est dans du court terme ce que ça
veut dire si on réussit à faire adopter
le projet de loi puis c'est l'intention
ça veut dire que par exemple je vais
pouvoir avoir les résultats scolaires de
la première étape le premier bulletin
qui arrive avant Noël alors avec ces
résultats qui vont être versés dans la
base de données on va pouvoir identifier
les écoles qui ont des difficultés
particulières les notes sont en bas de
la moyenne mettons dans certaines
matières
il est supposé faire ça il y a un xnome
d'écoles ils ont pas nécessairement les
systèmes pour pour savoir ça de quelques
centres de services scolaire qui ont des
systèmes informatiques de ce nom mais la
majorité n'en ont pas
alors là on va être capable de savoir ce
qui se passe et puis s'il faut
intervenir s'il faut déplacer des
ressources j'ai parlé des aides à la
classe là les éducatrices c'est ça à
table avec les syndicats la présentement
j'espère qu'elle m'a demandé on va
signer ça on va te permettre aux
éducatrices d'aller prêter main forte
dans les classes comme deuxième adulte
bon ben si on voit que certaines classes
qui ont besoin d'aide parce que
qu'est-ce que tu veux la classe c'est
plus difficile mais on va le savoir on
va être capable d'intervenir avant la
fin de l'année scolaire
ce que vous ne pouvez pas faire j'ai pas
l'info je le sais pas j'ai pas je les ai
les résultats de la première étape en
fait le résultat des bulletins je finis
par les avoir l'année scolaire est finie
un peu tard
vous créez ça a été salut j'entendais
des gens et j'ai droyés l'applaudir
l'Institut national en éducation il y a
déjà le conseil de supérieur l'éducation
alors vous vous coupez ça en deux vous
dites le primaire secondaire ça va être
un nouvel institut
la fonction
ça va être plus simple parce que là
l'Institut d'excellence
d'instinationales d'excellence en
éducation est créée moi ce que je prends
je prends les fonctions du Conseil
supérieur de l'éducation je les
transfert dans l'institut faites le rôle
conseil il va être à l'Institut ensuite
de ça tout ce qui est recherche en
éducation les fameuses données probantes
là qu'est-ce qui marche dans une classe
les meilleures méthodes pédagogiques bon
ben l'Institut va nous les identifier et
on va créer des contenus des formations
continues en fonction de cette de cette
science là et là c'est là que je ne
comprends pas les syndicats qui sortent
pour dire
pas content parce que parce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont contre la formation
continue Patrice c'est bon de la
formation continue c'est bon pour les
médecins ils vont me les infirmiers
c'est bon les psychologue c'est bon pour
toutes les professions pourquoi ça
serait pas bon pour les enseignants
depuis les enseignants et mon objectif
c'est pas de le de leur imposer des
contenus l'Institut national va
accréditer les fameuses formations puis
les enseignants vont pouvoir choisir
dans ce bouquet de formation alors là je
me dis s'il vous plaît cher syndicat
travailler avec moi puis pensez pas
juste à votre bataille syndicale pensez
à vos membres il me disent que la
formation continue c'est pas bon pour
l'autonomie moi je suis trop d'accord et
pour tout ça donc pour conclure
rapidement sur le pouvoir au ministre
vous aviez besoin de vous donner autant
de pouvoir à vous mais c'est parce que
si un moment donné ça ne fonctionne pas
parce que barrette qui a essayé de faire
ça ça a pas marché dans le réseau
si ça fonctionne pas un moment donné
pour le meilleur et pour le pire c'est
moi qui est le ministre
orientation si un moment donné j'ai un
DG qui dit Drainville les projets
particuliers d'un écoles secondaires je
veux rien savoir les aides à la classe
que tu veux amener je veux rien savoir
mais c'est parce qu'à un moment donné on
travaille tu ensemble ou pas si on n'est
pas capable de vous dire ça dans son cas
particulier je dois l'écouter je vais
bien
vous êtes content d'être à Montréal
ok par rapport à l'autre là
oui je suis content
de vous voir ce matin juin on apprend
qu'en juin 2022 juin 2022 c'était avant
l'élection juin 2022 c'est quand
j'arrive ça ok on apprend que le
ministère des Transports du Québec avait
demandé qu'on étudie la possibilité de
faire un tunnel juste avec du transport
collectif le public n'a pas su ça mais
ça a été demandé
ude ce que vous nous dites encore
Bernard drinville que pendant toute la
campagne électorale vous qui adorez les
chiffres je vous connais un peu vous
aimez les chiffres vous aimez les
données
j'ai fait campagne en regardant les
citoyens des yeux en disant dans ce cas
là les chiffres de notre côté les
données je les mets de côté parce que je
vous jure qui va avoir un tunnel même si
j'ai pas d'étude je vivais l'attente
puis elle était intense c'était
convaincu bien sûr j'étais convaincu
écoute je suis mauvais menteur fait que
quand j'ai pris mon engagement avec la
fougue la ferveur je fais que ça là
c'était pas juste porter avoir des votes
là
c'est pas ça l'histoire c'était non non
mais on a toujours dit les études on va
les mettre à jour mais le monde les gens
de non non je dis là
vous avez dit je le vois
le trafic on le vit tous les jours puis
arrêtez de nous de nous alors l'erreur
que j'ai faite ça nous arrive des fois
c'est que moi j'ai pensé que le trafic
que nous vivions pendant campagne l'été
passé c'était le trafic on allait vivre
pour le reste pour le reste pour la
période post pandémique et on s'est
rendu compte qu'une fois que les travaux
sont arrêtés il y a pas mal de gens qui
ont décidé finalement de rester à la
maison puis de continuer à travailler à
la maison est-ce que ça ne commande pas
pour cette fois-ci pour le nouveau
projet dans notre ville une prudence
élémentaire de dire avant va pas mettre
voir un troisième lien transport en
commun on va attendre d'avoir 4 5 études
mais c'est ce qu'on fait là
vous avez même dit un projet sur la
construction on a un projet sur la table
on a un projet sur la table puis
lorsqu'on est en train de faire c'est
qu'on est en train d'étudier le mode on
est en train de regarder le tracé et le
mode et le tracé ils vont très
certainement influencer le coût la
facture ou la faisabilité ben voyons
Patrice peut-être la faisabilité si on
se rend compte qu'on n'est pas capable
de creuser sous le fleuve mais tu as
peur pourquoi est-ce que le transport
collectif ce serait bon pour toute la
planète sauf la région de Québec le
réseau de Québec puis les vies aux
autres là transport collectif oh non non
mais c'est ça aussi le débat là le débat
c'est aussi il y avait un projet de pont
vers l'île d'Orléans
pour la 40 plus à l'est il y a d'autres
projets par-dessus l'île d'Orléans
savoir mais je répète ils l'ont dit mais
je répète le transport collectif
efficace il y a de l'argent à savoir là
qui est bon pour les autres les autres
agglomérations
usagers les gens de Lévy ont pas le goût
les gens de votre coin en ce moment ils
ont pas le bon moment c'est vrai mais un
moment donné un bon transport collectif
qui fait que au lieu de passer ton temps
dans le trafic tu penses sur le fleuve
puis c'est rapide puis c'est confortable
pourquoi on serait les seuls sa planète
n'a pas aimé ça si c'est promener dans
un transport collectif confortable puis
agréable puis pour lequel nous verrons
peut-être pas de début de construction
d'ici la fin
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit ce que j'espère
c'est qu'en 2026 j'espère arriver devant
les électeurs de Lévis puis les gens de
chaudière puis de capitale avec un
projet qui est en cours de réalisation
en cours de réalisation de quelque chose
de concret qui va prouver qu'on était
sérieux puis il décideront s'ils en
veulent aussi s'ils en veulent pas pour
le moment ils en veulent pas je suis
d'accord avec vous mais peut-être que
quand ils vont y croire
vos oreilles non pas du tout mais ils
vont commencer on va suivre cette
réforme en éducation ça doit suivre
beaucoup je suis bien intentionné puis
je veux que ça marche puis ça va être
bon je pense pour les élèves
ultimement c'est les élèves qu'il faut
aider à la prochaine merci merci à la
prochaine